en el vídeo pasado comenzamos a explorar
la noción de una función de error
recordemos que no hay que confundirla
con la esperanza en probar pues usan la
misma anotación aquí es de error pero a
veces también se usa ere de residuo como
la definimos simplemente nos da la
diferencia entre la función
efe y la aproximación de f por ejemplo
aquí en el dibujo tenemos marcado el
error para cuando x es igual a b es el
debe en realidad sólo nos importa el
valor absoluto de ed dejaba ponerle aquí
un valor absoluto pues a veces f es más
grande que el polinomio y a veces el
polinomio le gana a efe lo único que nos
importa es la distancia entre ambos
valores lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es intentar acotar el valor
absoluto de ed es decir me gustaría
poder decir que eso es menor o igual a
cierta acá donde acá es una constante
que pues a lo mejor tenga que ver con b
bueno eso es para b mayor que a vamos a
suponer todo el tiempo que ve es mayor
que a
ahora fíjate aquí ya habíamos obtenido
un resultado que estaba padre obtuvimos
que la enésima derivada de la función de
error era igual a la enésima derivada de
nuestra función entonces también van a
ser iguales en valor absoluto de modo
que si pudiéramos de alguna forma acotar
la enésima derivada de nuestra función o
bueno al menos en un intervalo que tenga
ave entonces también vamos a poder
acotar la enésima derivada de la función
de error y quizás con un poco de
integración y algunos trucos algebraicos
vamos a poder acotar el error mismo vale
entonces vamos a ver si podemos hacer
eso lo que vamos a suponer es que de
adeveras vamos a poder acotar la n más
undécima derivada de f
es decir supongamos que existe un cierto
valor m déjame ponerlo con otro color
vamos a ponerlo en blanco vamos a
suponer que esta n undécima derivada se
ve pues más o menos así esto de aquí es
f n más uno la n encima derivada en x y
lo único que me importa es lo que pasa
dentro del intervalo a coma
afuera no me importa sólo quiero saber
que aquí adentro está acotada bueno
entonces supongamos que el valor
absoluto de la enésima derivada está
acotada es decir por hipótesis sabemos
que aquí lo escribo
sabemos que el valor absoluto de la
enésima derivada aquí le puse en
mayúscula verdad ching bueno espero que
ese cambio no no no a ver déjame borrar
lo mejor me voy a poner con n minúscula
la n undécima derivada imaginemos que
sabemos que está evaluada en x en valor
absoluto está acotado por una m recuerda
esto de aquí es una hipótesis que
estamos tomando y pues nada más va a ser
en el intervalo en el intervalo de a a b
sale entonces
el intervalo a ver déjame escribirlo de
esta forma en x pertenece
como el intervalo cerrado incluye a y b
es decir x puede ser a v o puede ser
cualquier valor en medio de ellos dos
puede parecer un poco artificial esta
condición pero algo un poco más natural
es que va a existir este máximo estoy
aquí va a ser un máximo verdad entonces
máximo podemos garantizar que existe
este máximo si la n más undécima
derivada es continua entonces en vez de
suponer esta hipótesis tan rara vamos a
suponer que en este intervalo la enésima
derivada es continua vale entonces esta
expresión es lo mismo que esta otra
expresión es lo que demostramos en el
vídeo anterior
vamos a usar eso vamos a ponerle que
esto implica esto implica que a ver
vamos a ponerlo con la función error que
el error sin este es otro color vamos a
regresar al anterior ahora sí vamos a
ponerle que el error bueno y la enésima
derivada del error evaluada en x en
valor absoluto es menor o igual que
bueno esto está más o menos interesante
y se parece un poco a lo que queremos
pero todavía no es igual puede parecer
similar pero aquí tenemos una derivada y
allá queremos el error después vamos a
tener que pensar de dónde sale esta m
espero que con algunos ejemplos se
aclare pero insisto aquí tenemos la
enésima derivada del error que está
acotada pero queremos acotar el error o
sea el error por sí mismo
podemos pensar como la derivada 0a
entonces lo que vamos a intentar hacer
es integrar a ambos lados de la
desigualdad para ver qué obtenemos a ver
si llegamos a lo que queremos va
entonces deja de poner por acá una
integral de x y aquí otra integral de x
y vamos a ver qué sucede el lado
izquierdo es bastante interesante vamos
a empezar con eso tenemos la integral de
un valor absoluto sería más fácil si
tuviéramos el valor absoluto de una
integral y afortunadamente la
desigualdad nos va a salir muy bien
déjame escribir aquí un pequeño
paréntesis vamos a tomar la integral
empieza lo tanto vamos a tomar la
integral de fx de x y vamos a tomar la
integral
no perdón la integral de fx de x a
sabritas se ven igual pero aquí voy a
poner el valor absoluto adentro y del
otro lado voy a poner el valor absoluto
afuera entonces cuál de estas dos
integrales es más grande o más bien cuál
de éstas podría ser más grande vamos a
pensar en distintos escenarios y fx
siempre es positiva en el intervalo que
nos interesa entonces es como una suma
de positivos con valor absoluto es
positivo y todo que da positivo da lo
mismo el caso interesante es cuando
empieza a ver algunos valores negativos
entonces déjame dibujar un plano x para
que trabajemos un poquito con eso
entonces aquí tenemos el eje x ahí el
eje si f siempre es negativa bueno si f
siempre es positiva entonces aquí
tenemos puras sumas positivas y valores
absolutos de positivos tenemos puros
positivos que da lo mismo si f siempre
es negativa entonces que vamos a obtener
pues aquí tenemos una integral negativa
y entonces cuando sacamos el valor
absoluto se vuelve positiva y de este
lado estamos integrando puros valores
positivos entonces pensando en un
poquito de todas formas va a quedar lo
mismo
la cosa interesante es cuando tenemos
una mezcla de positivos y negativos algo
de este estilo en este caso cuando fsb
así entonces tenemos que pensarlo un
poco más esta expresión va a ser
integrar estas áreas
pero fíjate esto de acá va a ser
negativo entonces se cancelaría un poco
de las áreas y al tomar el valor
absoluto queda más cerca de 0 pero qué
sucede cuando tomamos la integral del
valor absoluto la gráfica se ve así y
entonces toda el área va a ser positiva
y no se cancela nada con nada entonces
va todo el área es positiva entonces
obtenemos una suma más grande y por
tanto la integral de la derecha esta de
acá usualmente es más grande que la
integral de la izquierda esto es
especialmente cierto cuando f toma
valores positivos y negativos pues en la
integral de la izquierda cuando primero
integramos y luego sacamos el valor
absoluto al principio se cancela un poco
de las áreas porque tienen el signo que
les corresponden y luego sacamos el
valor absoluto de un número que tiene
una magnitud menor vale entonces
usualmente el lado izquierdo es decir el
valor absoluto de la integral es
pero igual que la integral de los
valores absolutos
vamos a usar eso acá aquí tenemos la
integral del valor absoluto entonces eso
de ahí es mayor o igual que a ver
simplemente lo copiamos es mayor o igual
que el valor absoluto de la integral
entonces déjame ponerlo con otro color y
vamos a escribir el valor absoluto de la
integral de la enésima derivada evaluada
en x de x sale la razón por la cual esto
es útil es que de todas formas tenemos
la desigualdad en el lado correcto pero
además ahora podemos integrar esta
expresión más fácilmente la anti
derivada de la enésima derivada de e es
igual a la enésima derivada de entonces
esta expresión vamos a ponerla como el
valor absoluto de la enésima derivada de
x de nuestra función de error todavía no
he dicho esperanza por ningún lado
verdad esto también me confunde a mí
debe haberle puesto ere de residuo
bueno solo recordemos que no tiene nada
que ver con probabilidad
tengámoslo en mente esto de aquí es la
enésima derivada de nuestra función de
error que va a ser menor o igual que la
integral de emt x es decir menor o igual
que pues a ver m es una constante
entonces nos queda mx pero como es una
integral indefinida tenemos que
acordarnos de sumar una c cuando
trabajamos con cotas la filosofía es que
entre más chica sea una cota superior
entonces nos da más información de este
modo nos gustaría minimizar el valor de
esta constante c somos afortunados
porque tenemos información acerca de la
enésima derivada vamos a ver a qué me
refiero
esta función de aquí la enésima derivada
sabemos cuál es su valor en el punto a
verdad entonces vámonos aquí arriba
fíjate la enésima derivada en a es igual
a cero porque la enésima derivada de la
función es igual a la enésima derivada
del polinomio en a entonces si evaluamos
a ambos lados de esta desigualdad en a
voy a ponerlo aquí al ladito nos queda
que el valor absoluto de la enésima
derivada de la función de error evaluado
en a
es igual a el valor absoluto de 0 que es
cero y eso de ahí es menor o igual que
esta cosa eva lorena es decir menor o
igual que m por a más c viendo esta
parte de la desigualdad y restando emea
de ambos lados obtenemos que menos a es
menor o igual que sé eso de ahí nos da
una cota para c entonces dada esta
condición que encontramos en el vídeo
pasado logramos ver que se es mayor o
igual que menos m
vale entonces si queremos minimizar la
constante si queremos hacer que esta
cota sea muy buena queremos escoger se
iguala menos m esta es la menor sé que
podemos encontrar con las restricciones
que tenemos sale entonces vamos a tomar
se igual a menos m y listo entonces
nuestra desigualdad la podemos
reescribir como que el valor absoluto de
la enésima derivada de la función de
error evaluada en x la función de error
en o la esperanza tengo un mal
presentimiento con esto de la esperanza
y así pero bueno sigamos el valor
absoluto de la enésima derivada es menor
o igual que m
por equis menos a recordamos las
restricciones x debe de estar en el
intervalo cerrado
es decir x está entre a y b y puede ser
no puede ser b ya hicimos un poco de
progreso pasamos de la n más undécima a
la enésima derivada vamos a ver si
podemos seguir haciendo esto entonces
misma idea en esta desigualdad vamos a
integrar de ambos lados entonces pues
nos quedaría algo de este estilo la
integral aquí la integral acá y por el
resultado que probamos acá en la esquina
sabemos que algo todavía más pequeño que
este término de la izquierda
el valor absoluto de la integral de la
esperanza a no no sabía qué iba a pasar
no es esperanza más bien de la función
de error
bueno la enésima derivada de la función
de error evaluada en x de x otra vez la
desigualdad se da con la misma lógica de
acá arriba y esto de aquí es útil porque
ahora esta integral la podemos resolver
fácilmente simplemente nos queda la n-1
cima derivada de evaluada en x y por
supuesto con sus valores absolutos y
entonces eso es menor o igual que menor
igual que esto menor igual que esto y
hay que hacer esta integral cual es la
anti derivada de esta expresión pues es
m por x menos a elevado al cuadrado
dividido entre 2 lo hice muy rápido pero
puedes usar sustitución o ver de lejos
que esta expresión tiene derivada 1
tratarla como una variable aumentar su
exponente en uno y dividir entre el
nuevo exponente como todavía es una
integral indefinida hay que poner más c
otra vez nos gustaría poder acotar ese
valor de c
vamos a usar exactamente la misma lógica
que antes si evaluamos esta expresión en
a otra vez vamos a obtener 1
vamos a ponerle a en los dos lados
entonces a la izquierda cuando le
ponemos un a nos queda 0 fíjate teníamos
aquí la n encima derivada entonces vamos
a obtener que 0
aquí tenemos esto es menor o igual que
el lado derecho si ponemos x igual a
todo esto se cancela porque es x menos
al cuadrado se va más c entonces tenemos
que se es mayor o igual que 0 entonces
el menor valor que podemos darle a c es
cero así vamos a tomar c es igual a cero
sale lo voy a indicar tachando ce y
poniendo aquí cero la idea clave aquí es
que podemos seguir haciendo este
procedimiento repetidamente es decir
podemos integrar estos pasos así
sucesivamente hasta que lleguemos a pues
a ver vamos a integrar integrar integrar
y entonces podemos bajar todas las
derivadas hasta la cero décima derivada
es decir hasta la función de error aquí
le voy a poner arriba está el exponente
tantito un cero para que la pensemos
como la 0a derivada pero bueno lo que
obtenemos es que esto está acotado
es decir es menor o igual que la fórmula
queda así primero va una eme y luego la
multiplicamos por x menos a que
exponente pues veamos que siempre que
sumamos el exponente con el número de
derivada queda n 1 como estamos en la 0a
derivada el exponente va a ser n 1
finalmente tenemos que dividir entre y
pues mira aquí abajo le voy a poner n 1
factorial y de dónde sale este n 1
factorial si aquí arriba simplemente
tenemos un 2 pero pensemos por qué
apareció este 2 cuando integremos este x
menos a va a subirse a tercera potencia
y vamos a dividir entre 3 entonces va a
ser 2 x 3
cuando integremos una vez más se va a
volver cuarta potencia y dividimos entre
4 y entonces en el denominador nos queda
4 por 3 por 2 por 1 o sea 4 factorial en
general hay que dividir entre el
factorial del exponente que tengamos
pero lo interesante de todo esto es que
si somos capaces de encontrar ese valor
que acota la enzima derivada de nuestra
función en el intervalo a b entonces
tenemos una forma de acotar la función
de error en ese mismo intervalo / a
por ejemplo si supiéramos el valor de m
entonces podríamos acotar el error en b
como sigue
tendríamos que el valor absoluto del
error en b es menor o igual que m por b
menos ha elevado a la n-1 dividido entre
n más 1 factorial uff aquí sí que hay un
montón de matemáticas finas esto nos da
un resultado bien poderoso es hora de
que lo pongamos en práctica viendo
algunos ejemplos